[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء تقدمها لكم ميس
المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الانسان في خفض حبه
التوتر والتصعيد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
في كاف يلتقي الرئيس زينسكي ويؤكد حرص
المملكه على دعم الحل السلمي
الاستخبارات الامريكيه معلوماتنا تؤكد ان
بوتين واثق بقدرته على سحق اوكرانيا
عسكريا
الاسرائيليون والفلسطينيون يتفقون في
العقبه على تخفيف التصعيد وتجميد
الاستيطان لاشهر
عشرات القتلى بغرق قارب مهاجرين قباله
ايطاليا ودعوه لروما باصلاح قوانين الهجره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا من كاف حيث التقى الرئيس
الاوكراني وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان في كاز واكد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ان المملكه تبذل كل الجهود لتخفيف
معاناه الشعب الاوكراني وقال ان المملكه
قدمت حزمتين من المساعدات لاوكرانيا بقيمه
410 ملايين دولار وبدوره شكر الرئيس
الاوكراني مملكه على دعمها لجهود السلام
في هذا الاطار اكد ان اهتمام سيدي خالد
الشريفين واسمه العهد في الجانب الانساني
في اوكرانيا كبير جدا وقد اتى نتيجه ذلك
توجيه القياده بتقديم حزبتين من المساعدات
الانسانيه لاوكرانيا بمبلغ اجمالي 410
مليون دولار وقد وقعنا اليوم على اتفاقتين
تؤسس لتسليم هذه
الاعانات ونامل ان تكون
عونا في تخفيف معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في
هذه الازمه الانسانيه ولا شكل المملكه
تبذل كافه الجهود التي من شانها التخفيف
من معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في الداخل
والنازحين في دول الجوار
كما اكدى وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان حرص المملكه على حل الازمه
في اوكرانيا بالحوار وشدد على ضروره خفض
التصعيد وحمايه المدنيين
المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب ونحن في السعوديه لان لدينا قناع
راسخه ان اي نهايه للحرب يجب ان يكون
بالحوار ويجب الكاوله المفاوضات في اطار
مبادئ القانون الدولي والميثاق الامم
المتحده واحترام سياده الدول ولهذا سوف
نستمر في العمل مع جميع الاطراف للبحث عن
فرص الوصول الى هكذا تسويه كما وجلست
اعراض جهود المملكه الراميه الى ايجاد
حلول سياسيه للازمه الاوكرانيه ووقعت
السعوديه مع اوكرانيا مذكره تفاهم
للمشتقات النفطيه وبرنامجا للعمل الانساني
كما اعلن الصندوق السعودي للتنميه دعم
اوكرانيا بالغاز المسال ومشتقات النفط
بمبلغ 300 مليون دولار
منه ابو ظبي عبر زوما ينضم الينا فيتالي
فيتامين دبلوماسي الاوكراني اهلا بك سيد
جديانين باي اطار يمكن ان نضع هذه الزياره
وهذه اللقاءات التي حصلت اليوم بين وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه والرئيس ووزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني وايضا مدير مكتب الرئيس الامسكي
الكرام اولا
نشكر ونرحب بزياره وزير الخارجيه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى اوكرانيا ان هذه
سياره الاولى لوزير الخارجيه الدوله
العربيه الى اوكرانيا بعد بدايه العدوان
الروسي الشام وانها اشاره قويه من وجهه
نظره واشاره مهمه للغايه لدعم العالم
العربي لنا
وخاصه الان لما نحيي مرور عام للغزو روسيا
ومن الواضح ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تقف الى جانب القانون الدولي يعني تقف الى
جانب اوكرانيا وهنا اريد ان الفت الانتباه
الى كلام الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان سمعت
هذه الكلمات قبل قبل الدقيقه قال ان اي
نهايه للحرب يجب ان يكون بالحوار وعلى
طاوله المفاوضات
طبعا شدد وزير الخارجيه الامير فرحان بانه
يجب انهاء هذه الحرب بالطرق السلميه هل
نتوقع اي مبادره اي جهود سعوديه لارساء
هذا السلام في اوكرانيا
غضب بالضبط وتطلبه اوكرانيا قبل يومين فقط
صوت العالم العربي باسره لصالح قرارا
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده قدمته
اوكرانيا بمشاركه 60 دوله وان هذا القرار
مبني على صيغه اوكرانيا للسلام ويؤكد على
الضروره التحقيق سلام شامل وعادل في
اوكرانيا باسرع وقت وفقا لمبادئ نطاق
الامم المتحده يعني اوكرانيا والسعوديه
على صفحه واحده بشان فاهم وكيفيه انتهاء
هذه الحرب العدوانيه عن طريق سحب جميع
القوات الروسيه عسكريه من ارض اوكرانيا من
اجل استعاده السلامه الاقليميه وفقا
للقانون الدولي بالضبط مقاله الامير
فرحان فيصل بن فرحان
بالنسبه ايضا لهذه المساعدات يعني
السعوديه كانت سباقه ايضا بمساعده
اوكرانيا وما زالت هذه المساعدات مستمره
ماذا يمكن ان نتحدث عن اهميه هذه
المساعدات لاوكرانيا خاصه بعد سنه ايضا
هذه الحرب ما زالت مستمره
تمت مناقشه مجموعه من
يعني المدرجه في جدول اعمال الثنائي
والاقليمي ومن اهم المواضيع المساعدات
الانسانيه والمساعدات الاخرى لاوكرانيا
والاوكرانيين بهذه الاوقات صعبه ودار ودور
المهم للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في تبادل
الاسرى والتغلب على التحديات العالميه
للعدوان الروسي خاصه في مجال الامن
الغذائي والتنفيذ مبادره رئيس
الحبوب من اوكرانيا نحن نامل في مواصله
حوار مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذه
المجلات وكمان حبيت اقول في الانتباه الى
النقطه مهمه ثانيه ان التقارب العسكري
السياسي الروسي الايراني لا يهدد امراني
بل يهدد امن منطقه الشرق الاوسط وخاصه
منطقه الخليج نحن نتذكر ان سبتمبر عام
2019 هاجمت طائرات بدون طيار احد الحقول
النبيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اوكرانيا باستمرار من مثل هذه الهجمات
لاسيما اثناء الهجمات على البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه باستخدام نفس الطائرات المسيره
الايرانيه شكرا لك من ابو ظبي كنت معي عبر
زومبيانين الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه على
المشاركه معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء
[موسيقى]
في روسيا اقل وزير الدفاع وان المدى الذي
ستضطر معه موسكو الى الدفاع عن حدودها
ستحدده شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه التي يتم
توريدها الى اوكرانيا واضاف شايغو ان
روسيا لن تتراجع عن تنفيذ اهدافها من
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا لحمايه حدود
البلاد من اي تهديدات
قال رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه
الروسيه بل ان هناك ان هناك ايضا معلومات
جديده سنتابعها وهو عن الموقف الذي اتخذه
الرئيس بوتين والاستخبارات الروسيه التي
قالت ان قرار تعليق مشاركه روسيا في
معاهده الحد من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
والهجوميه صارت ثلاثه كان بمثابه مفاجاه
للغرب واكد على ان القرار كان منطقيا
وصحيحا تماما وكان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين شدد على ان روسيا لا تنسحب من
المعاهده بل تعلق العمل بموجبات مشيرا الى
ان مساله استئناف العمل وفقا لهذه الوثيقه
يتطلب اولا توضيحا للجانب الروسي كيف
ستاخذ معاهده ستارت في الاعتبار الترسانات
ليس فقط للولايات المتحده ولكن ايضا للقوى
النوويه الاخرى في النيتو
بدوره قال جهاز الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان
الرئيس الروسي واثق من نفسه على سحق
اوكرانيا وعن هذه التقارير الغربيه عن نقص
محتمل بالاسلحه وداخيل الروسيه قابلها
الرئيس الروسي السابق
بسخريه كبيره حيث اكد ان المصانع في روسيا
اعززت انتاجها بنحو عشره اضعاف وتعمل على
ادخال احدث التقنيات في مصانع اسلحتها
واتفاخر بان بلاده تعمل على تحسين الاسلحه
باستخدام المعدات الغربيه عاليه التقنيه
التي تم الاستيلاء عليها في ساحه المعركه
واوضح ان المهندسين روس يستفيدون من تفكيك
الاسلحه الغربيه واصفا ذلك بتحويل تجربه
العدو لمصلحتهم وفق تعبيره تصريحات مسجدات
تاتي بعد مقالته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
عن نفاذ المخزون الروسي من الطائرات
الايرانيه المسيره بعد اسقاط نحو 24 طائره
منها في اوكرانيا بدايه فبراير
الى المانيا وتعليقا على مقترح السلام
الصيني شكك وزير الدفاع بولس بيستوريوس
بخطه السلام التي اعدتها بكين لوقف اطلاق
النار في اوكرانيا وقال وزير الدفاع
الالماني في مقابله صحفيه ان طرحه خطط
السلام الصينيه بالتزامن مع التقارير بان
بيكين تخطط لامداد روسيا بالطائرات
المسيره الانتحاريه يؤكد ضروره الحكم على
موقف الصين بافعالها لا باقوالها
بعد ان كان الحل اصبح اليوم المشكله من هو
طباخ بوتين ومؤسس فاجنر كان راس الحرب
الروسيه في خطوط المواجهه الاماميه
باوكرانيا وقد يتحول لوحش مطارده فرئيس
مجموعه
وهو معرض للاغتيال او الاقصاء في اي لحظه
بحسب معلومات استخباراتيه لصحيفه تايمز
البريطانيه ووصف معارضون روس بريكوتين
بقرد يحمل قنبله يدويه اي يمكن توقع اي
شيء منه ما تكاثر اعدائه واضافوا ان مؤسسه
فاجنر يفتقدوا لاي مكان امن في روسيا
مرجحين ان حياته باتت في خطر بعد تحوله من
حل لاي مشكله بالنسبه للكرملين او كانت
خلافات بريكوجين تصاعدت خلال الاسبوعين
الاخيرين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ووصلت لحد
اتهامها بالخيانه وصناعه المزيد من
الاعداء ممن
ينتظرونك ومنه ايضا الصحيفه اشارت الى انه
بينما ينشغل بوتين بمعارك اوكرانيا قام
رئيس مرتزقه فاجنر بفتح جبهه اخرى ضد
قيادات في الجيش الروسي حيث نشر صورا
مروعه لجثث ثلاثين عنصرا من مقاتليه مرجعا
سبب موتهم لشح القذائف وحرمانهم من
الذخيره بتصرف مقصود من قاده الجيش
والدفاع الروسيه ودائما وفقا الاتهامات
[موسيقى]
من موسكو ينضم لاعب الجواد الرشد مراسل
العربيه من كاف ايضا ينضم اليه احمد
العربيه اهلا بكما معنا سابدا معك عبد
الجواد هذا التصعيد بين رئيس منظمه باغنر
وبين القيادات الروسيه ما هو سببه وفي هذا
التوقيت الحرج يعني بعد سنه من بدايه هذه
الحرب وهو كان فعالا هو ومقاتلي فيها
مساء الخير ميسون لك ولجميل احمد نعم
بالفعل يعني هي قضيه تعود وتظهر للعلم
بشكل كبير خلال الايام الاخيره طبعا
الحديث قال كثيرا بين قائد مجموعه فاجنر
وبين وزاره الدفاع
الكبير عدد طبعا الخزائف ومد السلاح لهذه
الحقيقه
خلال الايام
عبد الجواد اعذرني لا نسمعك بشكل جيد
ساعود اليك ليس ما يتم اصلاح هذا
العطل التقني وهذا الصوت مع المايكروفون
صوت الهواء ساذهب بهذا الوقت الى زميلنا
احمد باكاتو احمد ابرز التطورات اليوم
اكثر الجبهات المشتعله خاصه
ماذا نعرف عنها
احمد هل تسمعني نعم اهلا ميسون بك
وبالزميل عبد الجواد نعم اسماء
حدثها عسكريا هذا اليوم 11 غار جويه قامت
بها الطائرات الروسيه على مواقع الجبهات
المختلفه 17 هجوم برجبات الصواريخ على
الجبهات الشرقيه محاولات ورصد لمحاولات
تقدم من قبل القوات الروسيه في كل ميليمان
وبخمت في وطبعا ضخمه هي التي تشهد
اشتباكات الاقوى محاولات تطويق مستمره من
قبل القوات القوات الاوكرانيه المتمركزه
في المدينه من الناحيه الجنوبيه او من
الناحيه الشماليه هناك تراجع كما تقول
القياده العسكريه هنا
بضعه امتار 100 متر غالبا كل يوم هذا
تراجع تكتيكي كما تقول عنه القياده
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بالطابعه على مدفعيه
الروسيه تدك مواقع المقاتل الاوكران في
هذه المدينه بصوره مستمره
كان هناك محاولات استهداف واطلاق
للمسيرات الروسيه في منطقه كوبيانس شرق
خرقيف هذا الامر مستمر منذ ايام طويله ما
يجعل المواطنين يعني غالبا لا يقومون
بنزول الشيء للشوارع الا في الاوقات
الضروريه فقط لان الاستهداف لهذه المنطقه
بصوره يوميه كذلك كان هناك طائره بدون
طيار استهدفت المواقع العسكريه الاوكرانيه
في منطقه سومي في الشمال نحن نتحدث اذا عن
استمرار لهذا
الاستهداف من قبل الطائرات المسيرات
تستخدمها القوات الروسيه كذلك ايضا ردت
القوات الاوكرانيه باربعه غارات بطائراتها
بدون طيار على مواقع عسكريه ومعدات عسكريه
روسيه في الجبهات المختلفه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ايضا تحدث اليوم بحديث هام وقال
انه لابد من كسر الهيمنه الروسيه على سماء
اوكرانيا عن طريق تزويد الغرب لاوكرانيا
بطائرات اف 16 وكذلك او طائرات رونالدو
الايطاليه
الامر هام للغايه وان تكون هذه الطائرات
حديثه الطراز وبها يعني رادار حديث لكي
يكون هناك يعني يعني طريقه جديده لمواجهه
الهيمنه الروسيه على سماء اوكرانيا خلال
الفتره الماضيه ونحن نتحدث معك احمد ايضا
هناك مواقف لمستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
الذي يقول بانهما تواصلوا مع الصين
وحضروها من تبعات ارسال اسلحه الى روسيا
كما قال سوليفان بان معلومات الولايات
المتحده تشير الى ان حكومه الصين لم توافق
بعد على ارسال شحنات اسلحه الى روسيا هذه
ابرز المواقف من المستشار الامريكي
المستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ساذهب
الان الى عبد الجواد الرشد لكي ايضا يعيد
لنا سبب هذا التصعيد الان بين رئيس منظمه
فاجنر وبين القيادات الروسيات تفضل عبد
الجواد
مساء الخير ميسون واتمنى ان تكوني ان
تسمعيني بشكل جيد نعم في الحقيقه قضيه
فاغنر تعود وتظهر للعلن اليوم طبعا خاصه
بعد يعني السجال الطويل الذي جرى بين قائد
هذه المجموعه ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه حول
النقص في امدادات يعني ما يخص القذائف
والمعدات العسكريه ان كان ثقيله او خفيفه
طبعا ميسون خلال البحث عن هذا الموضوع
باعتبار ان مجموعه هي سريه للغايه وبشكل
كبير تمكنا من الوصول الى معلومات تتحدث
عن انر يعني لابد من الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
انها شركه عسكريه خاصه تعمل باستخدام
المرتزقه بشكل كبير في الكثير من القطاعات
لذلك طبعا القانون الرئيس لهذه المنظمه
يتحدث تامين المعدات العسكريه لهذه
المجموعه لاستخدامها في الاعمال القتاليه
هو يقع على ما على المهمه الرئيسيه للفريق
الخاص الموجود داخل هذه المجموعه طبعا
وزاره الدفاع موسكو عندما طرحنا عليها هذا
السؤال يعني اجابونا بانهم يقومون بامداد
بما يحتاجونه لكن طبعا تم استعجال الموقف
بشكل كبير من قائد هذه المجموعه والوصول
الى هذه التصريحات الثقيله طبعا يعني هو
شخصيا شخصيه بشكل كبير الكثير كما لاحظنا
ميسون اليوم تحدثوا والعديد من التقارير
ذكرت بانه قد يتم استهدافه قد يتم اغتياله
في احد النقاط لكن طبعا حسب دراسه هذا
الموضوع حسب الراي السياسي في البلاد يعني
الاسرع ان يموت بريجوجل يعني بطريقه عاديه
هي اقرب من ان يعني ان يتم استهدافه او او
اغتياله
الذي فيه نظرا لما يحظى
من داخل تحركاته ووسائل الدفاع التي تحميه
من حوله خلال تواجده في ارض المعركه اشكرك
عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
الصوت من المصدر كما اشكر زميلنا منك
العربيه دائما سنكون معكم لنطلع منكم على
المزيد من التفاصيل في النشرات اللاحقه
صمود المشاهدين غير متوقعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه لاثني عشر شهرا ما هو سببه
اولا معنويات مرتفعه لدى العناصر وخليط من
الاسلحه الغربيه ثلاثه من هذه الاسلحه
غيرت مسار الحرب وفقا لتقييم خبراء
عسكريين غربيين وسنتابع سويا ما هي اولها
صواريخ جافلون الامريكيه المضاده للمدرعات
وهي ايضا هذه الجافلين هي منخفضه التكلفه
تسمى بالرمح هي سهله الاستخدام ليلا
ونهارا وتصيب الهدف بسهوله مداه الاقصى
يبلغ
4,750 مترا كما نتابع هنا الصمود
الاوكرانيه ساهمت به ايضا منظومه
المدفعيه وهي عاليه الحركه حيث نتابع هنا
صوره لها هي راجمه صواريخ متعدده منصوبه
على مدرعات خفيفه هذه الراجمه ما هو
خمسه اطنان بامكانها اطلاق ست صواريخ في
الوقت نفسه يتم توجيهها بواسطه نظام تحديد
المواقع الجغرافي ويبلغ مداها نحو 80
كيلومترا كما نتابع قاذفه هايمرس هي سهله
التنقل والحركه ايضا بحيث تطيح للقوات
اصابه الهدف في وقت قياسي والتحرك بعيدا
لتجنب هجمات مضاده كما ساهمت بسبعين
بالمئه من التقدم العسكري على جبهه خيرسون
بحسب قاده اوكرانيين ما هو السلاح الثالث
الذي بنيت عليه مقدرات الهجوم الاوكراني
هي طائرات
بيرقدار وهي طائرات بين اقطار تحديدا تي
بي اثنين وهي مسيرات خفيفه الوزن هي اقل
بحوالي سبع مرات من طائره ريبر الامريكيه
طول جناحيها يبلغ اثني عشره مترا ما يسمح
لها
البقاء في السماء لمده تصل الى 30 ساعه في
الطلعه الواحده هذه الطائرات اثبتت
فعاليتها في اصابه الاهداف حيث يمكن لكل
طائره منها ان تحمل اربعه صواريخ كما
نتابع موجهه بالليزر طبعا من ميزاتها ايضا
القدره على تجميعها من قطع جاهزه
[موسيقى]
اخفت الاضواء هنا جمله باتت تسمع كثيرا
داخل مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني فالرجل تاثر
بصره خلال الحرب التي انهكته صحيا ايضا
الرئيس البالغ من العمر 45 عاما اكد تراجع
حده بصره بشكل كبير بعد بدء العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في بلاده وارجع احد
الاسباب للعمل لساعات طويله في اضاءه سيئه
او معدومه تقريبا
الحرب في اوكرانيا شكل التحذيرا ينذر
بالسوء بشان بلدهم تايوان فالصور المروعه
للحرب دفعت التايوانيين لاتخاذ قرار
التطوع كمقاتلين اجانب بصفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه لوجود التشابه بين احداث
البلدين وفق صحيفه ديل تيليجراف المقاتلون
التايوانيون ابدوا مخاوفهم من تنفيذ الصين
لتهديداتها وافعال ما قامت به روسيا في
اوكرانيا بالرغم من وجود خطه صينيه للسلام
بشان اوكرانيا فتايوان جزيره تدعي الصين
انها من ضمن اراضيها وهددت بالاستيلاء
عليها بالقوه واضافت الصحيفه البريطانيه
ان احد المقاتلين التايوانيين العشره لقي
حتفه في هذه المعارك
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمره نتابع في
سياقها
في تركيا تداعيات الزلزال لم تنتهي بعد
تحقيقات مع نحو 700 مقاول بينهم رئيس
بلديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اختتم الاجتماع بين
مسؤولين اسرائيليين وفلسطينيين ومصريين
وامريكيين في العقبه لبحث خفض التصعيد
وحسب وكاله الانباء الاردنيه فقد تم
التاكيد على ضروره الالتزام بخفض التصعيد
على الارض ومنع المزيد من العنف كما اكد
المجتمعون على اهميه الحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي في القدس دون تغيير
واكدت الحكومه الاسرائيليه والسلطه
الفلسطينيه الاستعداد لوقف الاجراءات
احاديه الجانب لمده ثلاثه الى سته اشهر
حيث يشمل ذلك التزاما اسرائيليا بوقف
مناقشه اقامه اي وحدات استيطانيه لمده
اربعه اشهر ووقف اي بؤر استطانيه لمده سته
اشهر وهو ما اعترض عليه وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي اليمني من جانبها هاجمت حركه
حماس اجتماع العقبه ووصفته بلا قيمه وتقول
انه لن يغير شيئا كما اتفق المشاركون على
الاجتماع مجددا في ش الشيخ في شهر مارس
المقبل لتحقيق اهداف اجتماعي العقبه
هذا ودع العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني الى التهدئه وخفض التصعيد ووقف
الاجراءات الاحاديه الاسرائيليه وخلال
لقاء مع منسق البيت الابيض للشرق الاوسط
شدد العاهل الاردني على ضروره اعاده
المفاوضات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
غائقه في ايه اجراءات احاديه الجانب من
شانها زعزعه الاستقرار وتقويض فرص تحقيق
السلام
من العقبه ينضم الى عماد العضايله مراسل
العربيه عماد اهلا بك معنى اهميه هذا
الاجتماع والاجواء التي رافقته
نعم ميسون اهميه هذا الاجتماع تكمن في
ثلاثه محاور المحور الاول هو جاء بعد جمود
في المفاوضات الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه وهذا
يسجل للاردن ان جمع هذه الطرفين على طاوله
واحده وبحضور ايضا يعني حضور دولي الحضور
الامريكي كان
متواجدا في الغرف المغلقه اليوم في هذا في
هذه الاجتماعات النقطه الثانيه ان يعني
البنود التي صدرت عن الاجتماع
والنقاط التي تم الاتفاق عليها ما بين
الطرفين الجانب الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني
ويعني الجميع دعا للتهدئه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وتعهد والتزم ايضا بالتهدئه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الجانب الاسرائيلي
تعهد بوقف عمليات الاستيطان ووقف ايضا
عمليات بناء استيطان وحدات استيطانيه
جديده كل هذه المحاور وكل يعني النقاط
التي صدرت عن اجتماع العقبه اليوم جاء
يعني مهمه جدا وكانت اهميتها تكمن في
تهدئه الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لكن
يعني وكما تحدثت يعني
تنفيذ هذه البنود على ارض الواقع هو يعني
هو ما يثبت يعني بعد تنفيذها على ارض الوا
جميع الاجراءات التصعيديه يعني ما لبث هذا
الاجتماع عن
الان حماس تقول بان هذا الاجتماع لا يغير
شيئا وبانه بلا قيمه سمعنا ايضا وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي يتحدث ايضا على موضوع
الاستيطان بانهم هم يعني لن يلتزموا بما
معناه الضمانات ان كان من قبل الولايات
المتحده تجاه اسرائيل او من قبل الدول
الاخرى اتجاه الفلسطينيين هل تحدثوا عن
ضمانات وضغوطات من الممكن ان يفرضوها حتى
يصل الجانبان الى هذه تهدئه وتنفيذ بنود
هذا البيان الذي صدر اليوم
ميسون لا يوجد ضمان في هذه الاجتماعات سوى
الضمان الامريكي بالضغط على اسرائيل
والضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه بتنفيذ ما
جاء في بنود اجتماع العقبه يعني بمعنى ان
يعني
الضغوط الامريكيه على الجانب الاسرائيلي
هي التي سيكون لها تاثير على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بوقف كافه الاجراءات احاديه
الجانب بالاضافه الى وقف عمليات بناء
وحدات استيطانيه واجتماع وهذا الاجتماع
الذي ياتي قبل رمضان وقبل رمضان بايام له
اهميه كبرى خاصه ان الوضع دائما يتفجر في
شهر رمضان المبارك تبدا الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه يعني تنفيذ بنود هذه هذا
الاجتماع على ارض الواقع يعني الضمانات
الامريكيه بالضغط على على الاسرائيليين
بتنفيذ هذه البنود على ارض الواقع الايام
المقبله ستثبت ذلك ان كان هذا يعني هذه
البنود ستطبق ام لا يعني وخصوصا ان بعد
الاجتماع مباشره
بتغريده وزير الامن القومي الذي قال فيها
انما الاجتماع او بنود اجتماع الاردن
ستبقى في الاردن وايضا بعض الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التي قالت انها حبرا على ورق
ما لم يكن هناك ضمانات امريكيه بالضغط على
اسرائيل لوقف التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه لن يكون هذا بنود هذه هذا
الاجتماع لن يعني تنفذ على ارض الواقع
وستبقى وستبقى حبرا على ورق ما لم يكن
هناك ضغوطات على الجانبين بوقف التصعيد
ووقف العمليات التي من شانها زياده التوتر
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه شكرا لك من العقبه
الى مراسل العربيه على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
الى ذلك اكدت هيئه الاسعاف الاسرائيليه
مقتله مستوطنين اثنين في عمليه اطلاق
النار جنوبي نابلس وذكر مراسل العربيه ان
القوات الاسرائيليه اغلقت جميع الحواجز في
بلده حوار جنوب نابلس بحثا عن منفذ
بالمنفذ الهجوم ولم يتضح على الفور عدد
المنفذين
[موسيقى]
كابوس زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا لم
ينتهي بعد فتدعيه مستمره عشرات والاف
المواطنين ما يزالون من دون ماوى من بينهم
من لا يريدوا مغادره ركام المنزل والمانع
اما فقيد لم تصله فرق الانقاذ فاضح جثه
واما ذكريات حياه كامله لعله يصل ما تبقى
منها اما فيما يخص بمحاسبه المتورطين من
المقاولين والمتسببين بتفاقم كارثه
الزلزال بسبب عدم التزامهم بمعايير
السلامه والامان واعداد المعتقلين منهم
فقاربت 700 مقاول قيد التحقيق والاعتقال
وللصدفه فمن بين هؤلاء المعتقلين اوكاكش
قواق رئيس بلديه نورداكي تابعه لولايه
غازي عنتاب حيث يتم التحقيق معه حول
انهيار عمارتين دمرهما زلزال وشويدت حين
مكانه هو المشرف على اعمال بنائهما
القضاء التركي يوسع دائره تحقيقاته بشان
حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوبي البلاد خليل ابن المدينه المنكوبه
هاتاي نجم مع اسرته لكن بيته سيهدم ضمن
هذه البنايه المتصدعه رغم انها شيدت حديثا
هذا هو بيتي لا يمكنني الدخول الى البنايه
التي شيدت قبل 12 سنه فقط تضررت كثيرا
بسبب الزلزال وسيتم هدمها اذا كان هناك
تقصير من المقاولين والمشرفين على بنائها
فيجب ان يحاسبوا على ذلك اما الجد محمد
فقد استسلم للامر الواقع بيته الذي كان
مؤلفا من اربعه طوابق انهار وتسبب في مقتل
13 من افراد عائلته ابني اوكانتي وبنتي
وبنتي وبنتي
وابني وزوجتي اتوفوا اولاد اولادي اثنين
واحد 15 واحد 16
انتقلوا الى رحمه الله
رقم 14 وكل شيء نظامي بس ايش صار صار
بناء نحو 200 شخص رهن الاعتقال فيما يجري
التحقيق مع مئات اخرين يشتبه بمسؤوليتهم
في انهيار الاف المباني تحت طائله ممارسات
بناء فاسده كما طالت الاعتقالات كذلك
مسؤولا بولايه غازي عنتاب تابعا للحزب
الحاكم وقد تمتد لاخرين
98% من البنايات المتضرره بنيت وفق قوانين
قديمه للبناء لا مشكله لدي اذا تمت محاسبه
كل متورط في فساد الابنيه الاخرى الجهات
الرسميه احصت الى الان تضرر اكثر من نصف
مليون منزل بشكل كامل ما يؤشر الى طول امد
التحقيقات بشانها واتساع دائرتها
كلما تقدمت اعمال رفع اطنان الانقاذ هذه
تكشفت معها حقائق جديده بشان التجاوزات
التي طالت تشييد البنايات الامر الذي فاقم
من اضرار الزلزال وخلف عشرات الالاف من
الضحايا عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
زيدان اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل
حول هذه التوقيفات وماذا عن تحقيقات الى
اين وصلت
نعم ميسون يبدو ان دائره الاعتقالات
ستتوسع بين صفوف المقاولين والمشرفين على
المشاريع بحسب اخر الاحصائيات التي اعلنها
اعلنت السلطات التركيه قبل قليل ارتفع عدد
الموقوفين الى 188 شخص من اصل 626 شخص
مشتبه به ايضا هناك 2008 شخصا وجميعهم
نتحدث عن مقاولين هم تحت الرقابه القضائيه
هذا يعني ان التحقيقات لن تتوقف بحسب ما
صرح وزير العدل
ظهر هذا اليوم تم جمع عينات من سبعه اكثر
من
7500 مبنى منهار تم جمع عينات وادله وقال
ان لن يتم ازاله اي ركام من اي مبنى قبل
وجود او قبل وجود فريق قضائي وفريق
لرفع الادله والعينات من هذه الابنيه
بالتالي هذا يؤشر الى ان عمليه الاعتقالات
لن تتوقف طبعا ش رئيس بلديه نورداغ يوم
امس وهذا يؤشر الى ان هذه العمليه لن
تتوقف عند طرف معين حتى لو كان من الحزب
الحاكم رئيس باديه نورداغ هو من حزب
العداله والتنميه لذلك هذه العمليه لن
تتوقف عند اي شخص مهما كانت صفته حتى الان
هذه المؤشرات تقول ذلك لا نعلم في
المستقبل كيف ستكون الامور لكن هذه
العمليات مستمره حقيقه يعني اولا هذه
العمليات مستمره لعده اسباب من ضمنها لا
شك ان الانتخابات قريبه ايضا هناك سخط في
الشارع من انهيار عديد الابنيه لاسيما
الابنيه التي شيدت خلال السنوات الماضيه
وانهارت بشكل دراماتيكي وغير مفهوم نتيجه
الزلزال لذلك الحكومه وتحديدا حكومه
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان تحاول تسريع هذه
العمليه بالتزامن مع عمليه اعاده الاعمار
التي بدات بشكل فعلي من نفس المنطقه من
منطقه نورداغ واصلاحيه
بالبدء بتشييد 655
مبنى في هذه او عفوا وحده سكنيه في هذه في
هاتين المنطقتين بولايه غازي عنتاب شكرا
لك من اضنه زيدان زنجلو مراسل العربيه على
كل هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
ارتفع سعر صرف الدولار بمقدار سته الاف
تومان مقارنه بالامس حيث وصل الى 60 الف
رغم اجراءات البنك المركزي التي تهدف الى
الحد من طلب المودعين على العملات
الاجنبيه او بالتزامن مع ارتفاع سعر
الدولار مقابل التومان وصف مسؤولون
حكوميون في جلسه مغلقه للبرلمان الاسعار
بانها غير واقعيه وفقا لتقرير مركز
الاحصاء الايراني فقد بلغ معدل تضخم
النقطي في فبراير الحاليه اكثر من 53% وهو
ما يظهر زياده قدرها نقطه مئويه مقارنه
بالشهر السابق
في ايران ايضا اضرب عمال شركه يازد للصلب
بالاضراب عن العمل وخرجوا في مسيره
للاحتجاج على ظروفهم المعيشيه وتدني
رواتبهم مقارنه بالاسعار المرتفعه
[موسيقى]
السلام
من ايران الى جارها العراق الذي يشهد
انخفاضا حادا في منسوب مياه نهري دجله
والفرات في ازمه مياه جديده تتهم بغداد
تركيا وايران بالوقوف وراءها
هكذا كان الفرات وهكذا اصبح في احدث صور
له ساحه للجري وميدان للتهكم عما وصل اليه
الحال في بلد تتلاطمه امواج التناحرات
السياسيه والاقتصاديه بعدما كان احد اغنى
بلدان الشرق الاوسط بالانهر
الصور القادمه من مدينه الناصريه مركز
محافظه ميسان جنوبيه العراق لانخفاض منسوب
المياه حركت السلطات على اعلى المستويات
لمعالجه قضيه المياه حيث عقدت الرئاسه
العراقيه اجتماعا موسعا كرس حول ملف
المياه في البلد
ازمه المياه المتكرره تعد ملفا شائكا
بالنسبه للعراق اذ تتهم بغداد مرارا
جارتيها تركيا وايران بالتسبب في خفض
كميات المياه الواصله الى اراضيها
وسياستهما في بناء السدود على الانهر قبل
دخولها الاراضي العراقيه وزاره الموارد
المائيه العراقيه قالت في بيان لها ان
الانخفاض الحاصل بالحصص المائيه في بعض
المحافظات الجنوبيه عائد الى قله
الايرادات المائيه الوارده الى سد الموصل
على دجله وسد حديثه على الفرات من الجاره
تركيا
يمتلك العراق اكثر من اربعين نهرا على
امتداد اراضيه بعضها تعرض لجفاف كلي
والبعض منها يعاني من جفاف موسمي بسبب
سياسات الجارتين تركيا وايران المائيه وهو
ما يعرض العراق لازمه مياه سنويا بحسب
وزاره الموارد المائيه فان اسبابا انخفاض
مناسيب الانهر يعود الى وصول 30% فقط من
حصه العراق المائيه بينما سبعون بالمئه
تضيع لدى جارتيه ولان الحكومات السابقه لم
تبرم اتفاقيات تلزم تركيا وايران بتامين
حصص العراق المائيه اضافه الى استنفاذ
الوزارتين السابقتين الخزينه المائي بخطه
غير مدروسه
وفقا للامم المتحده فان البلد المكنى
ببلاد الرافدين على مر العصور اصبح من
الدول الخمس الاكثر عرضه للاثار السلبيه
للتغير المناخي في العالم مع تراجع
الامطار وا درجات الحراره وازدياد التصحر
وهذا خبر عاجل موقف من رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو الذي يقول البناء
والقطاني في الضفه الغربيه سيتواصل وفق
الجداول المحدده بخلاف طبعا البيان الذي
سمعناه خلال الساعات الماضيه من خلال
اجتماع العقبه سنتوقف الان مع فاصل لنتابع
بعده في التاسعه هذا المساء
تقرير يكشف ان قاده من طالبان يحضرون
التعليم على الافغانيات ويرسلون بناتهم
للدراسه في الخارج
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن حرس الحدود
الايطاليه مزرعه 59 شخصا في حادثه غرق
مركب للمهاجرين قباله السواحل الايطاليه
وبحسب مسؤول ايطالي فان القارب انطلق من
تركيا وكان يقل افغانا وباكستانيين
وصوماليين وانه وفقا لشهادات الناجين كان
على متنه نحو 150 شخصا هذا فيما اعربت
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جيولوني عن نسفها
العميق واكدت الالتزام الحكومه بوقف
الهجره البحريه غير النظاميه لمنع المزيد
من الماسي بدورها طالبت المفوضيه
الاوروبيه حكومه ميلوني بضروره اصلاح
قوانين استقبال المهاجرين وتعديلها
في ايطاليا ايضا تشهد البلاد واكبر عمليه
تنصت في العالم تحت ذريعه مكافحه جرائم
العصابات المنظمه واحباطها حيث يوصف
التنصت على الهواتف بطريقه الوحيده
لاختراق عصابات المافيا ومعرفه الصفقات
الفاسده التي يبرمها كبار المسؤولين
والموظفين في الدوله غير ان افرادا وزعماء
من المافيات باتوا قادرين على معرفه اذا
كانوا تحت الرقابه او لا وذلك من خلال
تعاملهم مع اشخاص قادرين على الوصول الى
قوائم التنصت السريه لقاء مبالغ ماليه
وفقا لصحيفه تايمز البريطانيه وفي هذا
الاطار تجادل جهات حول جدوى عمليه التنصت
التي تكلف خزينه الدوله نحو 200 مليون
يورو سنويا فالاجهزه الايطاليه تراق هواتف
نحو 110 الاف شخص من رجال العصابات وتجار
المخدرات والموظفين الذين يشتبه في فسادهم
الاداري لكن مراقبين يؤكدون ان هذه
التكاليف يمكن تعويضها من خلال كميات
الاموال الضخمه التي تجري مصادرتها من
عمليات المافيات او صفقات الفساد
[موسيقى]
والان سنتحدث عن الموقع الذي يكتسب شهره
كبيره وهو تيك توك الصيني المشهور لا
يستخدمه الصينيون مشاهدينا لماذا الاسباب
تتعلق بالامان والمحتوى وحمايه
المستخدمين وفقا لتقرير تقني استخباراتي
امريكي اذا منصه تيك توك التي باتت احدى
اكثر التطبيقات شعبيه في العالم ليست كذلك
في الصين فبلد المليار يعتمد على نسخه
اخرى من تطبيق تيك توك تقدم منتجا اقل
ضررا ومصمما لحمايه شبابها في التفاصيل
التقرير افاد وهذا التقرير ايضا هو
لتقنيين مختصين من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
قال ان الصين تعتمد اصدار اصدارا محليا
لتطبيق تيك توك يدعى دوين وله قوانينه
التي تحمي
المستخدمين فدويين مشاهدينا
نفس مزايا تيك توك تقريبا لكن مع اختلاف
جوهري واحد حيث يطلب من المستخدمين الذين
تقل اعمارهم عن 14 عاما استخدام وضع
المراهقين من اجل حمايتهم وللحد من تاثرهم
بشكل سلبي ماذا يفعل دوين يقيد استعمالهم
له ب 40 دقيقه يوميا بين الساعه السادسه
صباحا والعاشره مساء وذلك لضمان حصولهم
على قسط كاف من النوم كما لا يعرض عليهم
سوى محتوى ملهم مختار خصيصا
بعنايه من مواد علميه وصحيه وغيرها حسب ما
اكد ياكولا ستايلان كبير مسؤولي البرامج
في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه لصحيفه نيويورك
بوست كذلك وبعكس تيك توك الذي نحن نعرفه
ونستخدمه والذي يستخدم طبعا خارج الصين
يراقب ايضا عبر مجموعه من الاجراءات
الوقائيه الوقت الذي يقضيه المستخدم
الصيني اليافع ايضا على المنصه وانواع
المحتوى المستهلكه اثناء المشاهده
[موسيقى]
في خبر متعلق بالسوشيال ميديا ايضا كشفت
دراسه طبيه عن ان الاستخدام المتواصل
لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي يؤدي الى افراز
هرمون الدوبامين بشكل مفرط وهو ما يسمى
بادمان نتابع
[موسيقى]
والان الى وضع الفتيات والتعلم في
افغانستان فبينما تستمر حركه طالبان في
حظر الفتيات الافغانيات من التعليم يرسل
بعض القدم من الحركه بناتهم الى الخارج
للدراسه واستكمال تعليمهم وفقا لتقرير
نشرته تايمز البريطانيه والتي اشارت ايضا
الى وجود انقسامات غير مسبوقه بين قياده
طالبان بشان حظر تعليم الفتيات ما اثار
بعض الامل في التغيير هذه الامل مشاهدينا
تصطدم بافكار زعيم الحركه هبه الله اخوان
زاده الذي تصفه الصحيفه بالرجل الغامض حيث
يرى ان منح النساء حقوقهن سوف يقوض سلطه
جماعتهم الصحيفه تقول ان هناك املا في
مقاومه ناعمه داخل الحركه نفسها لقرارات
زاده اذ يتم بالفعل تحدي حظر التعليم
بهدوء مثلا كالسماح بالمدارس المجتمعيه
غير النظاميه من قبل قاده محليين في
طالبان او بغض الطرف عن المدارس
[موسيقى]
من كعبول تنضم الى زينب حكيمه الناشطه
والاستاذه الجامعيه زينب اهلا بك معنا الى
اي حد هذه المعلومات دقيقه بانه قاده
الطالبان يرسلون بناتهم الى الخارج للتعلم
وبنفس الوقت يمنعون الفتيات داخل
افغانستان من هذا التعلم والتوجه الى
المدارس
تحياتي نعم من الحقائق المؤلمه مع الاسف
في قضيه تعليم المراه في افغانستان ان نفس
المجموعه التي حرمت يعني حرم نساء
افغانستان من التعليم ومن حق العلم عمل
يرسلون بناتهم الى خارج هذا حقيقه يعني
كنا نعلم من قبل هناك عدد من قاده طالبان
حتى
عائلاتهم تعيش خارج افغانستان وطبعا
بناتهم تستفيد من من فرصه التعليم والعمل
خارج افغانستان اللي عندهم امكانيات ونفس
الشيء يعني نفس الشيء حرم منها نصف سكان
داخل افغانستان زينب هل تعولون على هذه
الانقسامات والاختلاف في وجهات النظر داخل
قاده طالبان هل هناك من امل بان هذه
الانقسامات ستستفيد منها المراه الافغانيه
والفتاه الافغانيه وان يغيروا رايهم مثلا
ويعود ويفتحوا هذه المدارس ويسمح للفتاه
بالتعلم ام هذا الامر صعب
نقلنا بان
بان هذا الاختلاف وهذا الانشقاق داخل صفوف
طالبان يزيد من الامل في الغاء هذا الحظر
في المستقبل لان فعلا نحن نرى ان هذا
الشيء يدل على يعني ازدواجيه المعايير عند
طالبان في مساله حقوق المراه وتعليم
المراه داخل افغانستان فحتى قاده الطالبان
ايضا يعرفون هذا الامر وهم نحن حتى قلنا
بانهم في بعض من قاداتهم يحاولون فعلا في
بعض من يعني مسؤولين حكومه الطالبان
يحاولون فعلا
اقناع هذه الشيوخ اللي وراء هذا
حذروا المانع من التعليم ففعلا الامل
موجود يعني طيب هل لديهم تاثير برايكم
هؤلاء الذين يقنعون الشيوخ باعاده التعليم
هل هم يعني ذات نفوذ قادرين على تغيير
رايهم برايك
ممكن يعني الامل موجود يعني طبعا هم
مسؤولين كبير في الحكومه يعني قاده كبيره
في الحكومه فطبعا نحن نامل في ذلك ولهم
قدره على ذلك لكن اذا لم يفعلوا ذلك
فسيعود هذا الامر الى قيمه كبيره لشاب
افغانستان ولهم كحكومه وكحزب يعني سيعود
هذا
بايجاز المنظمات الحقوقيه الدوليه هل
تساعدكم هل هي قادره على هذا التغيير
لدينا 30 ثانيه لو سمحتي
طبعا المنظمات الحقوقيه الدوليه لهم تاثير
على حكومه طالبان من يعني عن طريق
الضغوطات اللي يضعون الضغوطات السياسيه
على دوله تاليفان طبعا لهم تاثير حتى عن
طريق الضغوطات اقتصاديه لكن لو كانت خاصه
بالحكومه يعني باشخاص حكومه بمسؤولين
حكومه طبعا لهم سوف يكون لهم تاثير في هذا
الامر ان لم يسكتوا عن هذا وان لم ينسوا
نساء افغانستان والا يعني لم يعتادوا على
هذا الامر نحن يعني نطالب العالم ونطالب
جميع الجهات بان يعتاد على هذا الامر لان
هذا سوف
يعود باضرار كثيره لنا والاجيالنا
المستقبلا لك يا زينب حكيمه الناشطه
والاستاذه الجامعيه كنتي معي من كابول
[موسيقى]
بعد انسحاب شركات السينما الغربيه من
روسيا انخفضت نسبه الزائرين
لدور السينما الى ما يقرب من اربعين
بالمئه لتصبح معرضه للاغلاق وسط تساؤلات
فيما اذا كانت الافلام الروسيه قادره على
انقاذ هذه الصناعه كاتيا من موسكو معها
التفاصيل
بعد مرور اكثر من 30 عاما على انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي تعود الان الى شاشات
السينما الروسيه الشخصيات الكرتونيه
السوفييتيه الكلاسيكيه بعد اعاده احياء
العديد من هذه الاعمال من جديد للرضا
بدانا في شهر يناير بعرض فيلم
حضورا كبيرا
ثلاثه عوامل متزامنه ساعدت على زياده
شعبيه هذا الفيلم وهي اولا نقص الافلام
المعروضه وبسبب شعبيه الشخصيه الكرتونيه
السوفييتيه
ولان عرض الفيلم تزامن مع عطله راس السنه
فيلم الرسوم الكرتونيه السوفيتيه احد
الافلام التي اعيد احيائها من جديد الان
حتى ما الارقام القياسيه بنسبه المشاهده
في روسيا التي بلغت نحو 10 ملايين مشاهده
واحتل المركز الاول في شباك التذاكر بين
الافلام الروسيه بعد اربعه ايام فقط من
اطلاقه
النادي السينمائي الدار الذي يديره الفنان
الشعبي الروسي اوليج اسس من قبل مخرجين
نلحقبه السوفيتيه ويعرض بشكل دائم من تلك
الفتره والتي تلقى حضورا كبيرا حتى الان
حاله الحنين لدى المواطنين الروس ليست فقط
الى الاعمال الفنيه في الحقبه السوفيتيه
وانما الى كل ما يتعلق بهذه الفتره من
تفاصيل الحياه اليوميه خبراء فنيون تحدثوا
عن ان نجاح هذه الافلام الان يعود الى
وجود حاله من الحنين الى الاعمال
والشخصيات في الحقبه السوفيتيه من قبل
صغار والكبار وحتى المتقاعدين من الروس
وسط غياب للافلام الهوليوديه بعد حظر
عرضها على الشاشات في روسيا كاتيا طعم
العربيه موسكو
نذكر بعناوين التاسعه هذا المساء
حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد
في كاف يلتقي الرئيس
المملكه على دعم الحل السلمي
الاستخبارات الامريكيه معلومات تؤكد ان
بوتين واثق بقدرته على سحق اوكرانيا
عسكريا
الاسرائيليون والفلسطينيون يتفقون في
العقبه على تخفيف التصعيد
والنتانياهو يتحدث بان البناء الاستيطاني
في الضفه الغربيه سيتواصل وفق الجداول
المحدده
عشرات القتلى بغرق قارب مهاجرين قباله
ايطاليا ودعوات لروما باصلاح قوانين
الهجره
التاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبار
العربيه تستمر مع
360 ما هي ابرز ملفاتك اليوم طاهر اهلا بك
ميسونه نحن سنتابع بكل تاكيد وتفصيل موضوع
الاطفال الذين يتهم الغرب روسيا باختطافهم
بينما تنفي الاخيره وسنتحدث الى دبلوماسي
في هذا الشان اضافه الى الشان الاقتصادي
الايراني المنهار وسنتحدث الى احد
المتابعين المتخصصين كوني معنا